ah
tipo
vamos a hablar en español únicamente y
allí derecha extrema no es juan carlos
garcía
a mi lado también peso
y vamos a hablar un poco de guanajuato y
de la escuela porque crees tú
qué buenos ratos es un lugar
bueno
para aprender español
bueno guanajuato es una ciudad muy
turística y muy importante
históricamente
aquí fue la primera batalla
en la guerra de independencia de mexico
entonces tiene un importante valor
histórico también hubo algunas batallas
tenemos muchos museos sobre estos
aspectos de la historia de méxico
también hay muchas ahora
departamentos de la universidad de
guanajuato entonces esto convierte a la
ciudad de guanajuato en una ciudad muy
cultural y con muchos atractivos
turísticos si yo puedo decir
y por ello son completamente de acuerdo
es muy agradable pero de dónde viene
siempre cada temporada es diferente todo
depende podemos tener todos los extremos
del mundo que se pueden imaginar
y todo eso es muy interesante
y dígame y los estudiantes
progreso aprende qué es la experiencia
aquí con los estudiantes
claro aprenden aprender muchísimo
español hemos tenido en estudiantes que
vienen a la escuela
prácticamente sin hablar nada de español
no entienden hola cómo estás no
entienden pero después de algún tiempo
dos meses tres meses
al final dejan la escuela hablando muy
y entendiendo muchas cosas de nuestro
idioma tenemos un programa muy
estructurado y muy eficiente la escuela
ha trabajado por más de 15 años en este
programa y en sus mejoras
entonces nuestro programa y nuestros
libros exclusivos en la escuela son muy
eficientes
y son y nos dan muchos resultados con el
aprendizaje y tengo también la impresión
que aquí la gente en la calle
es muy acogedora amable entonces es muy
fácil practicar su idioma fuera de la
clase qué
y muchos estudiantes son nuestros amigos
ahora
es como el vuestro de la escuela nos
interesa mucho que los estudiantes
nuestros amigos porque también es muy
interesante que conozcan nuestra cultura
y nosotros su cultura
y perdón y también con en general con
toda la gente en guanajuato siempre hay
muy buenas relaciones incluso para mí yo
no soy originario de guanajuato pero
cuando llegué aquí me di cuenta que la
gente es muy amable
este en general en toda la ciudad
tiene también cursos para no aprenden
test avanzados por ejemplo para mí sería
interesante estudiar sobre la literatura
americana o latinoamericana o española y
la historia de méxico porque ahora estoy
viendo libros sobre la historia de
bellido para comprender este país que
tiene usted para estudiantes más
avanzados tenemos un nivel de nuestro
programa que se llama gramática avanzada
plus y se estudian los aspectos más
importantes de la gramática pero con un
enfoque más idiomático y también tenemos
nuestro programa que se llama más que
español donde ofrecemos clases de
especialidad es el nombre que les damos
nosotros a estas clases que son clases
sobre historia
una política términos médicos leyes
mexicanas
de comercio internacional al comercio en
méxico la mayoría de nuestros profesores
tienen alguna especialidad en este tipo
de temas entonces cada uno de ellos
puede enseñar o ofrecer
estos tipos de clases obviamente si se
requiere que los estudiantes tengan un
nivel avanzado de español también las
podemos ofrecer para estudiantes
principiantes nada más que haya usamos
más inglés
bueno
gracias
house
dei
downey jr
doors
la derrumbe
relaxing
por qué
el de los aces
vedder
y
en el 6
luego acabe
en el callejón y en guanajuato